you
Dragons SpaceX we can confirm a good
side hatch leak check dragon copies good
lead
shuttle discovery to the for today's
[Music]
[Music]
- to the
[Music]
to you years of continuous on how we
accomplished that mission we're bringing
commercial partners we're fostering a
space economy so we're making sure that
we're always pushing forward always
taking that next step I think it's such
a privilege to be part of an
organization that recognizes if we're
not actually making steps and innovating
every single time we do this then we're
not truly answering humanity's called to
explore and to push those boundaries
Christina I know Bob and Doug are
veterans themselves but what advice do
you have for Bob and Doug given your
experience as a long-duration station
crew member well being able to live
onboard the International Space Station
and work there is just such a privilege
you know you're a steward of this
amazing laboratory that's bringing so
many benefits down to earth and also
learning how we can push farther into
the universe so it is quite an honor and
I think that's the main thing about how
it feels to be up there for a long
duration you know in terms of advice Bob
and Doug have been great mentors for me
they've given me advice for so many
years it's strange to be the one who
could be in a position to offer them
anything but I would say that as you
know shuttle Flyers they used to
participate in missions that were really
really intense go go go all the time
long-duration spaceflight is more of a
marathon than a sprint so I would tell
the
to take that moment enjoy it and you
know really welcome the opportunity to
have part of your mission be taking it
all in and sharing that with the people
that got you there
thanks again Christina always a pleasure
to hear from you and fantastic words
thank you for sharing thank you and my
pleasure so once again Bob and Doug once
Bob and Doug arrived at the station
they'll be greeted by astronaut kiss
Chris Cassidy but before we do that
let's toss to a briefing
you
hello everyone I'm astronaut Chris
Cassidy commander of expedition 63
onboard the International Space Station
flying 250 miles above the earth like
you I'm excited about today's launch and
the possibilities it will bring to
America into the world but also I'm very
excited that two close friends will be
arriving and joining the crew I had the
privilege of flying with Doug Hurley on
both of our first Shuttle missions back
in 2009 together we came to the
International Space Station and helped
construct the amazing facility that it
is today
although this will be my first mission
with Bob it was my honor to follow him
as the chief of the office when he left
back in 2015 to begin training for this
amazing mission personally I've been
very fortunate to fly in two different
spacecraft
launching from America on the shuttle
and most recently launching from
Kazakhstan in the Soyuz but I can't tell
you how exciting it is to know that
we're once again launching Americans
from the coast of Florida
and finally here's a story I'd like to
share with you back in 1981 John Young
and Bob Crippen lost on space shuttle
Columbia the very first space shuttle
flight marking the last time we flew
Americans on a brand-new vehicle
with them they flew an American flag
representing America's sanika prowess
thirty years later that same flag was
flown to the International Space Station
this flag remains here today waiting for
Bob and Dunn
our flag means so many things to our
country and this small piece of America
represents what we'll be able to achieve
together we'll never stop exploring
and so Bob and Doug can take this very
special flag home to earth where it
awaits its next journey to the cosmos in
a few years it bursts Orion crew will
take this flag with it around the moon
all of this starts today I'll be
watching outside the window along with
everyone else in America and around the
world
I can't wait to look out the window and
see my friends on close approach go
Falcon 9 go dragon and go Bob and Doug
I'll see you soon and that was a very
special message from NASA astronaut
Chris Cassidy right now the lone
American aboard the International Space
Station so he will be ready and waiting
to welcome Bob and Doug when they arrive
tomorrow if liftoff happens today little
later tomorrow morning the countdown now
stands at t-minus one hour twenty-five
minutes 54 seconds and counting
until launch and we'd like to share with
you just how much has happened here at
Kennedy Space Center since the last time
we had a crew on the pad launching from
here as you can imagine the end of the
shuttle era was a bittersweet moment for
many people across this spaceport but in
the end we knew we were striving for
this day and here we are joining us now
is Kennedy Space Center's deputy
director Janet Petro on the comeback
we've seen across Florida Space Coast
she's with Daryl nail now at OSP - Daryl
Thank You Murray Janet you were just
telling me you were there at the crew
walkout tell me a little bit about what
you saw between the astronauts and their
families so very historic it was very
emotional
so when doug and bob first came out of
the doors you know of course cheer went
up from everybody you know the vice
president was there Elon was there the
crew families was there and of course
Bob myself and the rest of the center
leadership was there to cheer them on
but then the you know when they came out
and then they went to the families and
Bob Behnken said virtual hug and he
shouted out a virtual hug and he did
this motion and of course his his child
also did that virtual hug and so I guess
that's the tradition of doing a virtual
hug with the families and then they you
know then they walked and got in the
Tesla either side and the family walked
right up to the window of the Tesla and
we're talking you know having a private
last moment with their with their father
hand on the wind I was very emotional I
had tears in my eyes I don't know
how many other people had tears in their
eyes but it was it was really a special
emotional moment and everybody was of
course wishing them well a lot of Allah
I love yous a lot of God speeds a lot of
ad astra you know take care all of that
so it was very special thank you so much
for sharing that with us and in in the
context of why it's so important Janet
you remember you've been here since 2007
yeah you were here in 2011 when shuttle
Atlantis came to wheelstop I've talked
to my uncle and father who worked out
here you know layoff notices went out
like the next day when the shuttle came
to a stop it was a very sad time Bob
Cabana
the director here called called it
depressing tell me about that time and
how far we've come
yes so as you as you note it was the end
of a very iconic program you know a lot
of people had spent their entire career
working on the space shuttle program so
135 flights all of them launching from
launch complex 39 many from 39a where
we're gonna be launching from today and
then returning back you know at the
Shuttle Landing Facility those two
iconic sonic booms was something that
all along the Space Coast people really
resonated with and really felt in their
hearts and look forward to so it was a
it was a very sad time but I will tell
you that 30-year program we had planned
for it the the workforce was incredible
you know there was there was a lot of
people who as I said spent their entire
career here and they wanted to safely
fly that shuttle out and then they
retired there was also another large
group of people that just wanted to put
on their resume that they had been
privileged to work on the space shuttle
so the the workforce I was incredibly
proud of because they were resilient
they were dedicated they were committed
to safely flying out that shuttle they
didn't skip any steps and regardless as
you said that they knew they were
getting their layoff notices I think it
landed on a Wednesday they were getting
their layoff notice on a Friday they
were in it till the end to make sure we
safely flew it out and of course you
know we had 14,000 workers out here then
which we have a lot fewer here today and
of course our guest operations you
remember those last shuttle flights
everybody around the country wanted to
be a part of that experience and we at
the center really leaned forward to
maximize how many people we could get
both on-site and never mind how many
people were lined up at the beaches all
along the river to watch that last
flight and of course today with kovat
unfortunately we weren't able to have
any on-site guest operations which was
pretty sad for this extort flight but
I'll bet that there is a ton of people
watching from the beaches or from even
their TV as we launch here today sure
there is and a tribute to your
leadership and Bob cabanas as well
getting things turned around here as a
multi-user spaceport getting the
commercial entities in here we
appreciate all that you've done to make
that happen
Janet Petro appreciate you being here
Thank You Daryl all right Marie we'll
toss it back to you all right thanks
Daryl and as NASA and SpaceX have worked
for years to get to this moment
today's mission opens the door to an
entirely new era in human spaceflight
not only for astronauts but someday for
the general public as well from the
beginning it has been our mission at
SpaceX to help make humanitary Wow
humanity a multiplanetary species and
today's mission is an important step
towards that goal the key to opening up
space access for people like you and me
is reusability without it traveling to
space is just far too expensive for the
average person to do imagine how
expensive a flight from LA to New York
would be if you had to throw the plane
away after a single trip exactly that
ticket would cost hundreds of millions
of dollars and almost no one could ever
afford to fly both the Dragon spacecraft
and the Falcon 9 rocket are designed to
be reusable which not only improves the
reliability of the vehicles and that
their flight proven again and again but
it also drives down cost this is
essential to enabling not just a handful
of people but rather hundreds of
thousands of people to get out there and
to explore the moon Mars beyond an eye
for one it is my dream to visit
Jupiter's ocean
Europa Leland you're one of the lucky
things that's had the opportunity to get
off the planet and go explore where
would you like to go next
you know Lord I think I would like to go
to Mars and you know be there if we know
a year about a year each way and then a
year on the Martian surface but the one
condition I would have to have my pups
would have to go with me because it's
about exploring new places but taking
your family with you you know we have
these crewmates that are people that you
get to know and love you know over the
course of training but it's nothing like
having your family with you and I think
that's something that we're going to be
seeing in the future people living and
working on other planets as a family a
lot of people who want to see your dogs
we've seen them in an official portrait
I know that the dogs came in with you to
take a picture in your spacesuit and
back in the day you know no dogs allowed
a NASA well they have their moment they
sure did and knowing that the
opportunity to fly to space as a private
citizen or a private dog maybe one day
is right around the corner we have a new
poll question on Twitter for you so if
you're given the opportunity would you
travel to space let us know and we'll
share the results a little bit later
right well there is not a lot of cargo
engineering technical ball for I'll just
keep farming in for countless
all right now while there's not a lot of
cargo in today's mission dragon is
carrying two special payloads aside from
Bob and Doug of course the first is a
series of custom art pieces entitled
humankind by Los Angeles artist Tristan
Eaton these indestructible double-sided
paintings are made from gold brass and
aluminum and they celebrate how far
humanity has come as well as how far we
still have to go it includes a beautiful
homage to the Saturn 5 rocket as well as
a nod to Bob and Doug's current ride to
space you can find more images and
information about these pieces on
SpaceX's social channels next in the
spirit of inspiring the next generation
of explorers we wanted to celebrate the
class of 2020 from kindergarten all the
way through graduate school SpaceX and
NASA invited students from around the
world to submit their photo to fly on
America's first human spaceflight in
nearly a decade
each graduates photo was used to create
a mosaic image of the planet Earth which
we printed and is being flown aboard Bob
and Doug's flight on the crew Dragon
spacecraft we received nearly 100,000
photos so thank you and congratulations
to all the world's graduates I am so
proud of what we're doing today and I
think about regular people fly in space
on a SpaceX rocket one day when I first
went to space I thought my primary task
of installing the Columbus laboratory
would be my aha moment but it was when
Peggy Whitson invited us over to the
Russian segment to have a meal she said
you guys bring the rehydrated vegetables
we'll have the meat and we you know
we're doing this having this meal and
it's with African American Asian
American French German Russian the first
female commander breaking bread at
17,500 miles an hour going around the
planet every 90 minutes and when I think
of that perspective shift that I got
looking out the window flying over my
hometown flying over Leo's hometown in
Paris flying over URIs hometown in
Russia it brought us all together as a
civilization and I think that's what
spaceflight does for us the more people
that have the opportunity to go to space
will feel like it's a it's an
international family of people
working together for the good of
humanity and all humankind absolutely
and it's exactly what that piece of art
was all about yeah
and following today's mission we will be
one step closer to a future where we can
all have that experience we can all have
that orbital perspective and the ability
to explore new worlds and just over an
hour from now Bob and Doug will be the
first people to launch on an American
vehicle and almost a decade for the team
at SpaceX it's really hard to put into
words how honored we feel about the
trust that Bob Doug and NASA have put
into our team to carry out this critical
mission I worked on crew dragon for for
two years and I can just imagine what
all of my friends and colleagues are
thinking right now as they sit in
anticipation and excitement for what's
to come
absolutely and speaking of those who
have carried the hopes and dreams of
science and exploration we have a few
shoutouts to share with you from some
big fans of NASA and SpaceX wow we're
making history again the NASA program I
am there with you guys in spirit Bob
good luck I know you'll be fine I'll be
watching and it got everything crossed
arms legs
I'm tighten or not can't wait for you to
get back safely this is the first time a
u.s. built rocket has taken people into
space in nine years is quite an
accomplishment so for us at the
Planetary Society more rockets means
more exploration more people in space
means more exploration more countries
involved in the endeavor of space flight
means more exploration this is how we
know the cosmos and our place within it
so congratulations SpaceX here's wishing
your team and the crew especially a safe
journey and the joy of discovery let's
go and a big thanks to William Shatner
and Bill Nye for those well wishes and
while we're keeping an eye on the pad we
want to bring in NASA astronaut Rex
Walheim if that name rings a bell
it's because he flew three Space Shuttle
missions to the International
a station including the final one by
Atlantis sts-135 he was one of the last
four people to ascend the tower at pad
39a and head to space and he currently
is deputy director of safety and mission
assurance at Johnson Space Center in
Houston Rex Walheim thanks for joining
us you and leland actually flew together
hey Rex Rex you flew on the final
shuttle mission we said STS 135 with
Doug in fact what's it like seeing him
in crew Dragon right now it's great this
is what we've been looking forward to
you know after the end of the shuttle
program you know it was a very important
time we wanted to transition to this
commercialization of spaceflight to
allow these commercial companies to take
our astronauts to and from the space
station so in the nine years we've had
since we last landed on Atlantis we
really worked hard for that we've worked
with our SpaceX partners and our Boeing
partners and here we are today's a day
we're taking that first step in this new
era what do you remember most about
launch day for sts-135 I think it was
just you you felt the the weight of it
this the Space Shuttle was a story
program 135 flights and thousands of
people had poured their lives into this
program to launch probes to the planets
to launch the Hubble Space Telescope and
then of course to build the
International Space Station so you knew
the incredible accomplishments this
program and so you wanted to finish
strong and then when it finally became a
launch day you'd finish the studying
you'd worked really hard and now it was
time to kind of soak it in and I think
that's what Bob and Doug are doing right
now we're sitting on the vehicle talking
to each other listen to the sounds and
feeling the vibrations as it starts up
and it's going to be it's going to be a
great great experience for them hi Rex
what is your take on private astronauts
going to space I think it's great I
think that the more we can do to
commercialize space to to make access
easier the better we are and I think
that's a part of this whole program you
get the cost down then more people can
afford it and you get the cost down you
can do more things in space more science
more research and
is a transformative experience to fly in
space and I wish more people could see
that when you look at on the planet like
Lehmann was talking about earlier with
your crewmates from different countries
all around the world it gives you a
different perspective it gives you a
perspective that we're all crewmates on
this planet Earth and we kind of get
that now with the pandemic we understand
that we're all in this together and
that's what the space program does and I
want to see more people get a chance to
see the Earth from that vantage point
and I think it'll bring us all closer
together he wrecks a very serious
question here the worm or the meatball
Leland I saw you dissing the war Morgan
how can you do that the worm is awesome
I'm so glad to have an ass and warm
insignia back it's great all right well
thank you very much Rex we appreciate
you and as we watch the as we watch Bob
and Doug they're in the capsule we are
an hour 10 minutes 57 seconds and
Counting from launch and we're going to
send it over to Hawthorne for an update
Jesse thanks Marie we're just an hour
and 13 minutes away were helped by our
closeout engineers to get into their
seats attach their suits to special
umbilicals that provide breathing air
pressurized nitrox
and a communication link to Dragon
systems they conducted leak checks which
were successful and communications
checks with the core here in Hawthorne
which is the person who will speak to
them directly throughout the entire
mission as well as the launch director
in Florida this is where they are
checking their comm path through both
ground stations and the tracking and
data relay satellites that we'll use to
talk to the crew the entire way to the
station that's right and after those
suit checks were complete the closeout
team was able to seal up the hatch which
also got its own leak check and we
confirmed that it was good to go
the closeout team at this point has
already departed the area they're about
25 minutes ahead of their schedule and
right now weather operators are kicking
off their final check on wind speeds at
the pad which are going to be NASA and
SpaceX are gonna do some internal go
polls just making sure conditions are
good with Falcon 9 to dry
and the crew the range and the space
station before the final go is given so
let's check back in with Houston real
quick for a status and the team there
supporting the space station on their
readiness for launch and will be able to
watch the launch of Bob and Doug Mission
Control Houston will largely be in a
monitor mode for the first 18 hours of
the flight with the team here really
jumping into the mix tomorrow when
dragon gets in range of the
International Space Station and we begin
integrated operations so I'll send it
back everything's green on our board
from the International Space Station go
Falcon 9 go dragon and Godspeed to Bob
and Doug all right thank you Gary if you
are just now joining us you picked a
really good time because we are one hour
eight minutes and Counting away from
launch this is our coverage for this
mission known as demonstration mission
two or demo two liftoff time still
holding for 4:30 3 p.m. Eastern tracking
no issues with Falcon 9 or dragon and
we're still waiting for that weather to
hopefully cooperate we're still tracking
a few things like precipitation and
flight through clouds we're hoping that
clears within the next 20 minutes or so
over the last three hours our crew
members Doug Hurley and Bob Behnken
donned their SpaceX suits in the
historic crew quarters suit up room and
made their way out to launch pad 39a
they walked out of the crew quarters
building just as every astronaut to fly
from this spaceport has done since
Apollo 7 they were transported to the
pad where the crew now on board the crew
Dragon spacecraft more continuing to get
views of them inside that cabin live
des is a historic lunch it will be the
first time a commercially built
spacecraft will launch people into orbit
and the difference the US has sent
people to the space station from
American soil since 2011 with the
retirement of the space shuttle program
over the next hour we will conduct a
series of polls to get ready for launch
have Bob and Doug arm the launch escape
system and begin fueling tonight's
launch is set for 4:30 3:00 p.m. Eastern
this will include a 12-minute flight to
orbit and then a 19-hour flight to duck
with the International Space Station at
11:30 a.m. Eastern Time tomorrow today's
mission is the culmination of years of
work between the teams at SpaceX and at
NASA demo2 is going to be an end-to-end
flight test we're gonna start with
launch today go all the way to docking
with the space station and then when Bob
and Doug come home splashing down in the
Atlantic and this is gonna be the final
test for NASA to certify SpaceX for
regular crew flights to the space
station and we've been hearing a little
from the crew onboard dragon which is
which they are currently strapped into
their seats as you can see on your right
screen they're already through their
seats or their they've already been
strapped into their seats and through
communications and leak checks they're
able to follow all the milestones still
ahead on those displays just above them
that you can see there go ahead
we're gonna equalize the pressures in
the common manifolds just to raise them
a little bit so we will be momentarily
cycling the tank isolation valves I just
wanted to let you know for hours I just
wanted to take a pause to listen into
the Nets okay we predict that day
so they'll be getting insight into all
of the dragon and Falcon 9 systems as we
proceed towards launch at t-minus one
hour and seven minutes let's check in
with John in sprecher
for a status update on both of those
vehicles with the update John well the
good news is we've had a smooth
countdown this afternoon SpaceX team is
working no technical issues on either
the Falcon 9 or the Dragon spacecraft
for the Falcon 9 operators have
completed where they are actually still
in work they're going to complete a few
minutes propulsion checkouts that are
being done on both the first and second
stages the team will be assessing their
launch readiness with a final go no-go
Paul that will come at t-minus 45
minutes and that'll be followed by
propellant loading starting at t-minus
35 minutes now earlier today dragon
operators performed a series of
checkouts of dragons flight systems the
spacecraft is also currently go for
launch
our NASA Crew astronauts Doug Hurley and
Bob Behnken that you can see inside the
Dragon capsule on the right hand side of
the display
they are currently going through the
various screens simple checks their
hatches close suit leak checks are
complete complex are good the next major
event for Dragon is going to be retract
of the crew access arm that you can see
on the left monitor up alongside the
Dragon capsule that's going to happen
somewhere between 45 and 42 minutes
before liftoff now the big one right now
is the range the range is currently red
for launch from historic pad 39a now the
air in the sea space is clear and the
worldwide network of ground stations as
well as the tracking and data relay
satellites they are ready to support
dragon as it heads into orbit but the
range
red for the weather we recently did
clear we went green for lightning but we
are still violating several constraints
rain accumulates field Mills which is
essentially you can tell that the
atmosphere is energized around the
launch site
we are expecting that will possibly
clear that we're going to hear a weather
briefing at one hour with the
expectation that those conditions may
clear shortly afterwards and allow us to
move into propellant loading also we've
been releasing balloons what we're
seeing at the upper altitudes is
conditions look good for Falcon 9 with
dragon no concerns have been expressed
by the GNC guidance team right now now
as a reminder today we have an
instantaneous launch window at 4:30 335
Eastern Daylight Saving Time or just
past 33 minutes after the upcoming hour
so we get one chance at it today but
currently t-minus one hour and three
minutes just passing that Falcon nine
dragon Argo the range is ready to
support but now we're waiting on the
weather is we've been expecting all
afternoon thanks John we've got an
extensive history now of flying Falcon 9
from the Florida coast and just last
year completed a test run of the mission
that were less than an hour from
beginning here today the purpose of that
mission was to demonstrate dragons
capability to safely and reliably fly to
and from the International Space Station
the success of demo1 was a really
exciting moment and it paved the way for
today's mission where we are just
moments away hopefully if we get that
weather from flying us astronauts from
US soil for the first time since 2011
Dragon and Falcon 9 together have years
of operational experience or what we
refer to as flight heritage as I
mentioned earlier spacex has
successfully completed 21 flights of
Dragon to and from orbit since 2010
including 20 trips to the International
Space Station not only have we conducted
thousands of hours of testing we've also
enhance
and add a number of safety features to
Dragon much of what was learned with the
cargo dragon was leveraged a design this
man cycling is complete expected
behavior and wanted to hear if you are
able to hear those
we actually did a we were just making a
comment about that heard some clicking
and and Bob watched it on the equipment
this plate though absolutely
and that again right there that's the
crew talking to the core here in
Hawthorne California who's going to be
talking them through out there a set up
held today so they were just doing a
quick check out Bob and Doug confirm
they were able to hear it sounds like
everything's still good so still no
issues with Falcon or dragon back to
what we were talking to is we're
describing these systems a lot of what
SpaceX did with cargo dragon has been
leveraged into this crew Dragon the
vehicle is designed to be fully
autonomous which means it can basically
fly itself but it also features a full
manual override capability if the crew
needs to take control in case of
emergency many of the other enhancements
helped towards SpaceX has goal of
reusability and less refurbishment time
between missions so let's take a closer
look at some of these advancements
standing at almost 27 feet tall from
bottom of the trunk to top of the
nosecone
crew dragons composed of two main
elements we have the capsule up top
which is designed to hold the crew and
any pressurized cargo and then an
unpressurized section known as the trunk
on the bottom and the nosecone at the
top of the capsule protects the docking
system as well as the guidance
navigation control system or what we
call GNC the nose cone opens for docking
and remains attached to the crew Dragon
spacecraft unlike the previous version
of Dragon that and that helps towards
our reusability 6 we are at t-minus one
hour or go for Section six when ready we
report go for launch
I think dragon will put affection picton
work so the career just has a couple
checks and when they are ready for
launch we're gonna hear them report to
the core that they are go for launch
continuing to walk you through the
Dragon spacecraft opposite of that nose
cone is the trunk we can see it on the
left hand screen there where it's kind
of split right down the middle with the
left side black and the right side white
the trunk provides an attachment point
to Falcon 9 the Dragon capsule and can
carry any cargo uphill on the outside
one half of the trunk contains a
radiator that rejects heat from the
active thermal control system into space
using SpaceX's new pica tiling
technology the other half contains solar
cells that are used to charge the
spacecraft's batteries during flight and
you heard that call-out right there for
lunch the next up will be the gonna go
pull at t-minus 45 Bob and Don or go for
launch and we're holding in the five
you're hearing it alive from Metz this
is amazing very exciting the spacex is
designed the spacecraft is designed to
accommodate up to seven crew members
with modular seats that can be removed
and replaced by additional cargo the
seats are made of carbon fiber and will
be custom size for any crew members
flying on board that control panel
that's centered between the pilot and
Commander seats consists of three
touchscreen displays and that just again
allows the crew to operate the vehicle
and fly it manually but also look at all
of their procedures relative position
over the earth the space station any
alarms alerts anything that they could
possibly want to do on draggin us
through those touch screens
and lastly our super Draco launch escape
system is a key safety feature of crew
dragon giving the crew the ability to
safely escape from the time of launch
all the way to orbit and that launch
escape system was put into work a little
bit earlier this year again on that
in-flight abort test as we look to the
future beyond this test light the first
operational SpaceX prude mission for
NASA will be a little bit later this
year after Bob and Doug come home NASA
astronauts Mike Hopkins Victor Glover
and Shanna Walker and sweetie Noguchi of
the japan aerospace exploration agency
or JAXA were chosen to support this
mission being called crew one but today
Doug Hurley is the spacecraft commander
for this mission
he previously flew on to space shuttle
missions as the pilot on sts-127 and STS
5 which was the final space shuttle
please review your launch akavit
criteria
again this is to review and confirm the
violation launch commit criteria we are
tracking what is very excited yeah
very bold also go for arming and watch
escape system and ago for propeller and
this is the on continent countdown net
reporting that technical poll was
completed all systems are proceeding
we're monitoring the weather as LD
briefed we are also looking at a watch
item on a hydraulic QT rod ring ring
pressure will come up at minus 8 minutes
30 seconds and will be able to verify a
decay rate no concerns at this time
everything is reading nominal but
watching that item no other constraints
on falcon or ground system
Stage two rp1 bleed is complete
all right we just crossed the 55 minute
mark away from launch sitting right next
to Doug Hurley who's closest to your
screen is NASA astronaut Bob bankin he's
the net he is the Joint Operations
commander for demo2 and bankin
previously flew on to Space Shuttle
missions sts-123 and sts-130 and also
served a tour as chief of the astronaut
office so here's a little bit more about
the man who said testing out a brand new
spacecraft is an astronaut's jury
[Music]
when you go through the launch day
preparations there's a lot of moments
that that kind of stand out to you one
is the kind of the celebratory piece of
it which is that you're walking out of
the suit-up room and getting in the
vehicle that's going to take you to the
launch pad when you close the hatch now
that's really when Doug and I are in the
vehicle and it's our vehicle and you
know we're really in control of the
mission at that point test pilots their
tasks prove that man could fly into
orbit around the Earth and return live
and well to talk about it there's always
a balance of managing risk as you go
forward to execute a test point and
figuring out a way to you know collect
the data we hear a sound okay is that
sound an expected sound or we see a
light is that light an expected light
what's the source of it does it sync up
with something else that's going on or
not
so trying to dissect all of that in real
time in your head is you know a lot of
things happen like that on on launching
of a vehicle from st. and Missouri
he is an Air Force colonel and flight
test engineer he flew aboard space
shuttle Endeavour twice introducing NASA
astronauts
[Music]
my career at NASA has kind of spanned a
couple of decades at this point I
arrived with the class of 2000 went
through the training program primarily
focused on the space shuttle and the
International Space Station learning
those systems having launched a couple
times on vehicles you know the the
second time was definitely different
than the first time you can feel a
little bit guilty of hey should I study
one more thing or one more piece of
information I should get am i really
prepared or not so that's definitely
different between where I was on my
first flight and where I'm at right now
it's been really interesting I think for
both my wife and I to have gone through
the process of seeing each other launch
in space I've seen her take that risk
and had it be in front of her and I've
done that to her there's just something
different about watching a rocket launch
when there are people on board you feel
a little bit differently about the pit
of your stomach and I can only tell you
it's multiplied significantly when it's
somebody that you know and then somebody
of course that's a family member it's
even multiplied more for me personally
as a spouse watching everything that bob
has put into this over the last five
years the dedication that he's shown the
perseverance is pretty special for both
of us though the way our minds work it
won't be until sort of the mission is
complete that you have really a chance
to savor it and celebrate it this is a
huge accomplishment for an Air Force
flight test engineer to be part of the
demonstration mission of a brand-new
vehicle it's going to be amazing without
a partner that has that same
appreciation I think it can be
challenging for some folks there's a
there's a lot of work and a lot of time
that takes away from family that know
that my spouse appreciates and I love
her for that really my role on the demo2
mission is to make sure that we get this
vehicle tested and evaluated so that we
can move on
to more operational missions at the
International Space Station we've got a
lot of objectives onboard the vehicle
that we need to accomplish to really
make sure that it's good to go
we'll make sure all those systems are
working during the test flight so that
the future missions will have them
available even if they don't plan to
utilize them through years of the the
NASA team I'm helping to share that
experience and teaching them the lessons
that we've learned by going through this
now there's another capability in the
u.s. besides NASA to operate something
of this magnitude when is the last time
humans launched on a new vehicle
certainly on the American side it's been
several decades
when multiple vehicles under development
it's a great time from a space
exploration timeframe just to see all
that happening and it's because of this
nurturing of the environment being able
to pull in a wider group of people who
can contribute towards a human
spaceflight it's just it's a super cool
time on a deeply personal level I'm
really excited that my son is got to get
a chance to see me launch into space
being an astronaut has been a little bit
of an abstraction thing for him because
he's seen me do it in old videos but he
hasn't seen me do it for real and so I'm
excited for him to see this launch I
want to thank the entire Commercial Crew
program team that's worked together to
get to this point where we've got
vehicles in the launch pad ready to head
to the International Space Station
[Music]
we're just over forty nine and a half
minutes away from launch of the Falcon
nine caring dragon to the space station
right now the launch director and the
launch team are preparing for a
readiness for launch Paul in this Paul
the thirteen members of the launch team
will electronically indicate a go for
launch this is also the go for
propellant load now we're gonna hear
that in a couple of minutes so while we
wait
we are tracking you watching from all
over the country we're seeing large
numbers of you logging on or tuning in
from coast to coast as well as around
the world we want to know is this your
first time watching a launch live if not
how many of you seen before tell us
using the hashtag launch America from
your favorite social media website as
for me this isn't my first one I've seen
a lot but everyone is exciting now
coming up we're going to go into a
readiness poll as I mentioned currently
right now on other nuts the SpaceX
launch director is checking to verify
the dragon team is ready and that the
NASA launch management team is ready
they'll come back at about t-minus 47
minutes with instructions to the SpaceX
Falcon 9 team to make their final
assessments then they log into the
procedure it's a little different than
the old days where you hear a Go Go Go
you know position by position all up and
down the row in this electronic age
everybody just clicks on whether they're
go or no-go the launch director will
then at t-minus 45 minutes summarize the
end of the poll and will then provide
instructions for the team at the same
time we will begin getting ready for the
crew access arm retract and we'll show
you that on one of the screens that
we've got up
now currently we are continuing to
monitor the weather the weather is still
red it is improving we're looking at
oneself between the radar and the pad
we're keeping our fingers crossed that
conditions will improve but we're going
to be watching that for about another 15
minutes so it looks like we're going to
be good to begin propellant load once we
hear the poles but we still have to get
the final get the range green so that we
can actually do the launch in just 47
minutes from now let's listen to
countdown net for a moment
right now coming up on 46 minutes son
seconds before launch didn't hear any
significant chatter coming over
countdown one is lost rekt at a cat down
net pole is complete and we have a go to
proceed with propellant load logic
control proceed with swing in the crew
our main car our move-in 40-45 minutes
thank you lots of control
a reminder control room on hold and
launched gate protocol the not urgent
no-go conditions brief CER LD and it
will approve aborting the launch out of
sequence and receive a launch abort for
urgent issues affecting the safety of
the operation operator shall call hold
hold hold on the countdown net launch
control will abort the launch of the
sequence immediately and proceed into
the launch abort auto sequence operator
shall also advise the launch director
whether structural break up are fires
imminent or occurring her dragon manual
escape flight rules remainder out fire
alarm instructions here in fire number
four event of a fire alarm key operators
previously briefed or remain at their
posts while alarm is evaluated and
haven't that personal safety is
threatened we will evacuate to the south
facing emergency exit which leads
directly outside one final reminder
they'll be arming the launch escape
system momentarily need all personnel
please stay in your seats from now
through orbit insertion and dragon
separation from the second stage
reactive armor ejector started and
you've heard Mike Taylor the SpaceX
launch director give instructions to the
team we've also just heard the call the
crew access arm retract is underway
great view from the camera inside the
white room as we see the arm moving away
from the Dragon capsule one of the major
events necessary to get down to t0 the
next one coming up we'll be arming of
the escape system on the Dragon capsule
now right now the next plan for Falcon 9
t-minus 35 minutes we will begin loading
propellant onto the first and second
stages now currently Falcon 9 is looking
good dragons looking good the range
continues to be go for launch in terms
of the clearance around the launch pad
both the air and the sea space looking
at the flight corridor the ground
stations the NASA tracking and data
relay satellites are ready to support
and we just continue to monitor the
weather our team is getting constant
updates we're monitoring weather data
sensors around the launch site looking
to make sure that we can get everything
into the green position the one that
we're mostly looking at right
now is how much rain we're going to get
between now and the liftoff whether it's
just going to be mild precipitation
that's within the rules for loading
propellant that's what the expectation
is but we're going to continue to watch
that so fingers crossed but right now
coming up at t-minus 43 minutes 18
seconds and counting
everything but the weather's go and the
weather is trending in the right
direction so we've got a fingers crossed
here
[Music]
at this time we're gonna send it back
over to Kennedy Space Center as the
action is picking up on the launch pad
thanks John I now that countdown clock
is continuing to tick and we are 42
minutes and 46 seconds away from launch
now as you just saw the crew arm
retracted that is the last major visual
milestone before liftoff and we should
be hearing out on the net soon's
confirmation that the launch escape
system is armed when that happens all
eight of the super Draco throttle off
valves are opened which means that those
engines can ignite okay so that means
those throughout those eight throttle
valves are opened and if those super
Drago's needed to fire in order for
Dragon to escape off of the pad they
could and so things running just a
little bit ahead of schedule right now
you'll bleed is complete
now we just saw the crew access arm or
track just a minute ago we saw a NASA
astronauts Doug Hurley and newer visors
are closed and we're arming the launch
escape system so we just heard the
astronauts confirm that they are about
to launch excuse me
arm the launch escape system that
happens just before fueling begins which
we expect to happen in just a couple of
minutes we saw a Bob and Doug suit up a
little over three hours ago then we
watched them drive out to launch complex
39a they were assisted by the SpaceX
ground team with crew dragon ingress
that happened a little before two
o'clock this afternoon and then we saw
the spacecraft hatch closed and again
just a minute ago we saw the crew access
arm retract we just heard that the crew
armed the launch escape system and in
just a few minutes we are going to hear
the call that they have started
propellant loading
magis cape system is verified armed so
we just heard that verification that the
launch escape system is armed or
switching to Gen 2
and we are going to send it over to
Hawthorne to take us through prop
loading Jesse from the parachutes to
launch escape system SpaceX has designed
crew dragon and Falcon 9 to be the
safest vehicle launch vehicle ever flown
and joining us today we have SpaceX is
Nick Picone who was our mission manager
for our in-flight abort mission earlier
this year and currently works on the
Starling team thanks for joining us Nick
hey Jesse I'm here at the launch and
landing recovery center with the
recovery team our dragon ground
operations team monitoring watch awesome
can you tell us more about the critical
safety features on this new version of
Dragon sure so dragon 2 was designed
with long-term reuse and reliability in
mind so fundamentally there are multiple
layers of redundancy to any of the
failure modes that we could conceive of
the NASA could conceive of when we were
working to design and test this vehicle
over the past few years but in the event
that we encounter an unforeseen filler
mode or multiple failures which push us
outside of our design space dragon also
has backup systems and operational
controls intended to keep Bob and Doug
safe I'm sure you've heard a lot about
it today but the launch escape system is
primary the primary backup system that
we have from the moment that the vehicle
is here on had be fuel all the way up
until orbital insertion at a high level
the launch escape system in the event of
a major falcon anomaly or emergency will
terminate falcon thrusts separate dragon
from falcon and it will use dragon speed
super Draco engines to quickly pull the
vehicle away from any kind of Falcon
anomaly now you talked a lot about the
launch escape system how exactly is that
activated is it autonomous is it
manually activated definitely so for
this system to work as design you have
to remember that the vehicle could be
flying it hundreds or thousands of miles
an hour through the lower atmosphere so
it's really important that it's a
extremely fast and highly reliable with
very low chance of false positives the
launch escape system fundamentally is
set to look at a set of pre-programmed
criteria which are onboard
dragon and Falcon are looking at higher
aid telemetry looking for abnormal
vehicle dynamics loss of communication
between critical systems or manual
commanding our launch director and chief
engineer whom you've heard a lot from
today are capable of sending a manual
command to Dragon to initiate a launch
escape and Bob and Doug are also always
able to to actuate the launch escape
handle and initiate a launch escape
themselves as well now that the system
is armed all of this is currently active
on the vehicle wow it sounds like
there's a lot that goes into it and we
did have an inflatable test earlier this
year to test this out can you tell us
what we learned from that test
definitely it was possibly the most
flight-like test of an orbital class
booster in history it was a fully flight
light test using a full Falcon 9 rocket
which we had to knowingly destroy in
order to get this fully integrated
system folks who didn't get a chance to
see it the vehicle followed a normal
crew launch trajectory about a minute
and a half into flight we had dragon
autonomously trigger the launch escape
system based on a reconfiguration of
those triggers as I think perfectly we
had we we continued through flight had a
successful parachute deployment and
splashdown and then we did see Falcon
rather spectacularly blow up about 10
seconds after separation it's important
to recognize that all of that happens
from command to actual separation of the
vehicle and under half a second
well yeah that sounds amazing thank you
so much Nick for joining us and talking
through those details with us enjoy the
launch today so we're gonna send it back
to KSC with Lauren Thank You Jessi we
are about a minute and a half away from
propellant load at t-minus 35 minutes we
should hear the call out on the nets
that propellant load has started so
that's about a minute and 13 seconds
away
hey Marie and Lauren I am getting goose
bumps over here it's just an exciting
moment when I was sitting in the vehicle
when we retracted everything when all
the loaded the problem was getting
loaded up I was just going through my
crew notebook I was thinking about you
know what my first step would be if
there was a malfunction because usually
everything goes nominally when you fly
to space but you have to think about the
things you have to take care of you know
the first step you have to take care of
and my mission I was calling out the
abort calls like if we had lost an
engine where we go next when the
different abort calls around the country
and around the world so I think that's
what those guys are probably thinking
about now and just really getting ready
for this this mission to go go off
absolutely and we're just now about 20
seconds from when we expect propellant
loading to start again that's fueling of
the rocket all right we're getting close
we should hear that call out any second
now on the net so let's listen in
I thought load has started fantastic
so prop load has started we've started
loading liquid oxygen on stage 1 and
stage 2 and y at liquid oxygen and our
p1 which is our rocket grade kerosene so
now that we are thirty four minutes and
42 seconds away from the first launch of
astronauts into orbit from American soil
since 2011 we know that the launch
escape system is armed which happened
just before fueling dragon prop load
happened weeks ago actually just a few
months miles down the road of what we
call Dragon land and those propellants
which are nmh or monomethylhydrazine
that's our fuel and nto
or nitrogen tetroxide that's our
oxidizer those not only feed the draco
engines that propel dragon on orbit but
they also supply those eight Super eight
super Draco engines of the launch escape
system so I have one right here a little
model Oh doesn't come off the stand very
nice so as you can see the dragon is
actually broken up into four quads and
each quad has two of the super Draco
engines for a total of eight of them and
as I mentioned they are by prop engines
they have mmh and nto is their oxidizer
now most abort systems from past space
vehicles I believe like Soyuz Mercury of
hollow they all had an appointee escape
tower on top where there was essentially
like a mini rocket engine or series of
rocket engines on top and if they
weren't used those that that escape
tower would have to jettison itself from
the vehicle if it was used it would be
used to lift the vehicle off of the
rocket
well dragon is a little bit different in
that it's escape system it's actually
integrated into the vehicle and that's
great for a couple of reasons one one
less thing you have to jettison on a
nominal flight and so they're pretty
dormant just those throttle valves open
unless they're used and hopefully they
never have to be and yeah I mean the
other thing that that offers you is the
ability to escape from the pad all the
way to orbit because if you jettisoned
your escape system prior to that
couldn't say yeah that's that's a little
dragon there era much safer design yeah
absolutely thanks for walking us through
that Lauren again the launch escape
system is armed that protects Bob and
Doug so that if something were to go
wrong they can shoot off of the pad away
from the rocket and parachute to safety
in the ocean that is such a crucial
safety capability and so now we want to
go over to Hawthorne for an operational
update with John thanks Marie we are
counting down those final minutes
everything is still looking good on the
Falcon 9 and the dragon vehicles for an
on-time launch but weather is trending
the wrong way right now we're keeping
our ears open in case we hear that the
weather is going to be no-go for the
rest of the count right now we are
counting down at t-minus 32 minute day
to unlock at t-minus 35 minutes right on
time the propellants we use on Falcon 9
are a fuel which is rocket grade
kerosene also called RP one of refined
petroleum we use an oxidizer and that's
the super-chill liquid oxygen or LOX as
we call it those two propellants with
you know come together but they don't
like so we need an ignition source to
complete the fire triangle for this
Falcon nine uses a fluid called t tub
you might see that just before first
stage ignition or maybe later in the
second stage ignition you get a green
colored flame as the t-top comes out
into the oxygen and that ignites the
main engines right before the rocket
takes off or the second stage engine
lights now currently in the fueling rp1
fuel is about ten percent full on the
first stage that's the bottom two-thirds
of the stack of the vehicle you can see
on the left the first stage is that a
long white cylinder at the bottom plus
that black cylinder called the inter
stage that's the entire first stage that
we're loading with LOX and RP one
kerosene that's the part that comes back
to earth the second stage just above it
the white cylinder and then above that
will be the dragon trunk and the capsule
now currently the second stage is also
loading fuel with our p1 that's about
eight percent full right now
we are loading liquid oxygen on the
first stage the second stage liquid
oxygen load will begin at t minus 16 and
a half minutes if the weather cooperates
so locks loading will then continue on
both the first and second stage until
the last few minutes of the countdown
helium loading is also underway in two
pressure vessels on the first second
stage we use that to pressurize the
tanks in flight as the propellant is
being pulled out by the merlin turbo
pumps dragon onboard the spacecraft you
can see the astronauts are monitoring
systems while propellant is loaded into
the Falcon nine now one way demo flight
last year and then the in-flight escape
test earlier this year the sounds inside
the Dragon capsule were recorded so as
part of the training the sounds of the
propellant loading were played back to
acclimate the crew to what they are
experiencing now I'm stopping I'm
listening to some discussion on one of
the back nets trying to track where we
are with the weather criteria we're just
passing another weather gate right now
trying to see whether or not the
conditions are go in certain situations
when the weather is no-go you have to
wait 30 minutes and we are now inside of
30 minutes but if the cloud moves away
if the conditions improve we may be able
to continue to countdown for another 14
minutes and reassess so we're waiting to
see whether or not we can continue the
count currently we are the range they're
ready to support with no problems in the
air in the C space area but again the
weather that's the one that's looking
bad and we're gonna continue to listen
and as a reminder today we have an
instantaneous launch time so at this
point if we hear a hold for any reason
we're going to have to stand down and
target our backup launch opportunity on
may 30th
for demo to Bob and Doug's flight to
station will take about 19 hours and
their journey is fairly similar to the
trip our cargo dragon makes back and
forth to the International Space Station
with two noticeable differences ducking
and splashdown as we await t-minus zero
in just a little over 28 minutes from
now ground operations seems just doing
those final series of system checks
making sure both dragon and Falcon 9 are
ready for liftoff and really keeping an
eye on that whether you're just
continuing to get live views of the
teams you've got Falcon 9 and dragon on
your left and that both Bob and Doug on
the right is they prepare at the Cape
for liftoff once we hit T zero and a
successful launch occurs we will watch
Falcon 9 and drag and make their ascent
until Falcon 9 and first and second
stages separate and send dragon on its
way to the space station and once it
gets on orbit mission operators will
prepare dragon for on-orbit operations
where dragon will execute a series of
burns that are gonna gradually raise its
orbit to align more closely with the
international space station and you're
seeing some of that track in the
animation on your screen right now
after doing enough for a wagon
it sounds like we're gonna get a weather
update real quick for the crew yeah
we're currently just evaluating one
constraint no constraint on the field
mill rule which looks at lightning
energy dissipation we expect to have an
update at about t minus 20
more information there and whether we
would be able to continue into the prop
load or or scrub at that time
okay gang back for the update we
appreciate it copy so do some more words
in about six minutes
okay so it sounds like we're gonna find
out in about six minutes if we're gonna
have enough time and John I was
referring to a couple of those weather
situations where we have to have a
certain amount of time in this case with
the field mils about 15 minutes so they
have until about 16 minutes and 30
seconds to really make sure that we're
gonna have enough time for that to
dissipate so we're gonna be listening
for that weather update in just a couple
of minutes but it is gonna be a pretty
interesting trip uphill for them once
they actually get on orbit and a very
exciting countdown with six minutes to
figure out if we are launching today but
targeting back to what we were talking
about next will dragon will make its
approach and actually dock with the
space station this is a very different
process from what we've seen with dragon
cargo deliveries in the past which used
a process called birthing and birthing
requires a spacecraft to approach the
station and then stop so a crew member
can maneuver the station's robotic arm
to capture the spacecraft docking on
this version of Dragon can be done
autonomous okrug started autonomously
with no crew aboard the station it's
typically a faster process both when
arriving and leaving but it does still
require pinpoint accuracy to approach
safely once captured a spacecraft thing
gets attached to a common berthing
mechanism it's the same type of port
that we use to connect each of the
modules together onboard station it's a
little bit slower process than docking
but the hatches are significantly larger
than docking ports to make them perfect
for bringing up large cargo items dragon
will spend up to 120 days dock before
preparing to return home following
successful completion of dragons test
objectives and cargo loading operations
the crew will close out the cabin
perform final system checks and
configure the vehicle for undocking once
the automated undocking sequence is
complete dragon will complete two
departure burns using its draco engines
pushing it away from the space station
and then after dragon departs the
station it's ready for its trip home and
that'll have deorbit entry and landing
and the number number of other
operations if you're looking at this
animation it might look like we're
playing the one we played originally in
Reverse because that's kind of how it
goes but just a little bit quicker all
of the operations following the final
departure maneuver will include things
like trunk separation closing that nose
cone again executing a deorbit burn and
once they're inside the atmosphere
deploying drogue and then main
parachutes and then finally splashing
down off the Florida coast at which team
time teams will move in get Bob and Doug
up out of the water and get them out of
the capsule once they're on the boat so
we have four minutes now until we get
that next expected weather update let's
go down now to the team at Kennedy
worried alright thanks Dan if you're
just joining us we are now t-minus 23
minutes and 48 seconds from the first
launch of astronauts to the
International Space Station from US soil
in nine years we're gonna find out in
less than four minutes if the weather
looks good for that and this will mark
the beginning of a new era where more
people will be able to fly to space than
ever before in fact we took a poll a
little bit earlier to ask you if you
have the opportunity to fly to space
would you go and 86% of those of you
watching answered that you would go to
space that's an incredible number I
think you know realizing that you don't
have to be a military astronaut or a
NASA astronaut to fly in space you can
be a regular savile you know just a
regular purse and going off to space on
a spacex type rocket so I think that's
why the numbers are so high yeah and we
are really thrilled to to see all the
folks watching along online I know we
certainly hope that that this is a go
but we're again we're gonna hear a
little bit of a weather update in less
than three minutes now and Leland you
know I know they're waiting for a
weather update and they've come you know
almost all the way down the count what
do you think Bob and Doug are thinking
about right now
you know we on 120 and STS 129 we were
having some weather problems and I think
we were getting close to the countdown
and then it seemed like the sky just
cleared up right above our heads we saw
it and we knew we were going and
you know we always know that you know
you can have any types of delays fuel
prop delays all kinds of things that can
happen but we've trained over and over
and over again for these types of
scenarios and so you know we want to be
safe we want to be safe for our families
and well you know do this another day if
it doesn't work with the weather I love
that John I always says whether it's
that thing that everybody talks about
but no one can do anything about it and
it is this interesting thing of just you
know succumbing to the mother earth
she's gonna tell us if we can go or not
today right yeah well if it happens I
mean and look at it this way Bob and
Doug got one really great rehearsal in
right it's always best to practice and
practice and practice yes so again we're
less than two minutes now from that
weather update that is going to go
directly to Bob and Doug and we will
quiet down so we can listen in for that
because I know we can't wait to find out
what that is and those of you watching
that have been following along we are
eagerly awaiting to hear whether the
weather is going to be a showstopper
today
this clouds can seem really deceiving at
times right you see the blue skies
peeking through and you think
everything's fine but you just don't
know so we have those launch weather
officers absolutely and I know you know
we've talked about it before but it's
not just the weather in Florida that
they're looking at they've got to look
at weather downrange if they if they
were to have an abort in flight and they
needed to come down somewhere and the in
the ocean they need to consider what the
weather's like out there because
recovery teams have to go out and get
them in a situation like that so there's
so many variables and that's why not
just with this flight but you know with
every human spaceflight we've had in the
past there's always a very good chance
of-of a scrub because because you do
have so much criteria that you have to
meet and we're gonna listen in now we're
just seconds away from a weather update
h2 our people unload complete
that is liquid oxygen you see venting
off the rocket that's completely normal
and expected we're standing by for a
weather update unless you can give us
another 10 minutes I don't think we're
going to get there with any of the rules
today thank you 10 minutes I mean
another 10 minutes pass t0o
1645 local I think we probably clear on
all the rules but not quite not quite
gonna make it for this okay we're gonna
check back in with you about two minutes
and then I'll call it up that about a
scheme I 17 minutes okay yeah we got
there someone were starting to count
down but we still have one above 2000 so
if that gets below
and that didn't sound great right there
that was the weather net going out but
we're still standing by for a final
decision
and we're going to continue to listen in
for an update but in the meantime we're
going to go over to John instructor at
SpaceX headquarters in California John
and Dragon SpaceX on whether we're still
10-8 to America and Karen LD is are
still expected update from LT waiting in
about another minute for one final check
with whether we're gonna check at 17
minutes possibly we don't really expect
that things will have improved the
weather officer was not optimistic that
the weather would clear up that rapidly
we did hear the launch director might
take Taylor joke that you know if we
could move ten more minutes past the t0
weather conditions may improve but might
was not able to do that we have an
instantaneous window today so at 17
minutes we want to make that call
because shortly after that we will begin
loading liquid oxygen on to the second
stage so if we're not going to have the
opportunity to launch water continued to
violate a couple different weather rules
that now do not expect to clear in time
to allow for and launched today today's
launch attempt watch out of sequence and
proceeded to be launching for
autosequence please
patro board has started
and Dragon SpaceX unfortunately we are
not going to launch today you are go for
5.10 zero launch scrub
5.10 zero it was a good effort by the
teams and we understand and we'll meet
you there we've heard the call from the
crew they have been informed launch
director mike taylor has called a scrub
for the day and we got the feedback when
the dragon team informed bob and dog
they said we gave it a good try what
they understand and we are here to try
another day so right now we did
officially hold the clock it looks like
a team - 16 minutes 54 seconds the
launch automatic sequence that controls
the Falcon 9 the loading of propellant
for the cycling of valves that is also
stopped we now proceed into what is a
normal scrub sequence for us we practice
this every launch so now we move into
safely taking the propellants the
pressurization gasses back off the first
and second stages as things begin to a
safe configuration then we will disarm
the escape system on dragon we got down
to just inside 17 minutes spacecraft we
had the fuel loading going on we had a
liquid oxygen loading going on
everything what's second stage and the
weather just needed a little bit more
time to clear the condition where we
didn't have that time because we had an
instantaneous window and so with that
SpaceX launch director had to call upon
the for these safety rules that we have
for this flight so right now the team is
undergoing the post scrub operations on
both dragon as well as Falcon 9 working
with the range no issues being reported
right now as we start to go through that
sequence everything looks good and Dan
we're a we had a good webcast going here
until the very end so you know we'll
look at it is and now we've had another
great dry rehearsal last Saturday we did
a dry one I should say and today we've
done a wet dress rehearsal but sorry we
just couldn't get there down
yeah thanks John I and obviously we
can't control the weather we came right
down to the wire they're hoping we could
just squeeze in between those cloud
systems get a launch today but it wasn't
to be but it doesn't mean this we're
done we're gonna have another attempt
coming up in just three days so we're
gonna be doing this all over again
essentially on Saturday on the 30th and
that launch attempt is going to be
coming at 3:22 p.m. Eastern Time so a
little bit earlier in the day it's gonna
look largely the same to everything that
we saw today with the crew waking up
going through suit up making their way
to the pad so it's good we're gonna feel
a lot of deja vu I think on Saturday but
still exciting safety is always first so
if weather was not there for us today
hopefully Saturday it will be there for
us and we will have a safe launch on
Saturday
yeah the initial weather report still
had us at about I think a 40%
possibility of violations so weather a
little bit better but we're still gonna
be kind of rolling the dice it is
Florida in the spring and summer so
storms are always a possibility one of
the good things though the vehicle
appeared to be in great health
throughout the day both dragon and
Falcon 9 so we didn't have to scrub for
any technical issue we're gonna continue
and follow along with Bob and Doug until
they're out of that capsule as again
they had started loading fuel onto the
Falcon 9 rocket so they'll have to wait
until all that fuel comes off
they'll disarm the launch escape system
which still stays armed because they're
still sitting on on a partially loaded
rocket and then once they're able to
disarm that launch escape system the
crew arm will swing back out they'll
make their way once again back the way
they came and then we'll be back to crew
quarters for Bob and Doug for a few more
days
[Music]
but if you're just now tuning in
wondering why we're not still counting
down we did have a launch scrub today we
were just a little understanding along
and I feel for its are novel or offload
expecting about a 40-minute upload that
answer that call out the the locks the
liquid oxygen fuel pumping out of the
first stage of the Falcon nine
everything looking good with that
expecting about forty minutes for all
that fuel to come off so again once that
fuel comes off Bob and dog will be able
to disarm the launch escape system and
that crew access arm will swing back out
they'll be able to make their way back
down and then over to crew quarters so
unfortunate scrub today because of
weather that was the one thing we were
tracking from the moment we started
today watching Bob and Doug get suited
up for their launch we did abort today's
launch or scrub today's launch with a
little under 17 minutes to go until our
t0 time which was 433 so that's gonna
move us to our next attempt which is
coming up on Saturday and that time is
going to be 322 p.m. Eastern Time so a
little bit early earlier in the day for
Bob and Doug and for everybody else
watching around the world they're still
gonna have a 19-hour flight to station
if that's when we launch and a lot of
this stuff that we saw today is gonna
look very similar but we're just going
to try again cross our fingers hope for
a little bit weather better weather
and again this goes with every lunch we
do track everything all the way down to
zero to make sure that everything is go
making sure that the ranges go whether
is go so this is standard procedure we
always tend to make sure that we have a
backup de launch day in case we do ab
scrubs like today so this is this is
pretty normal and standard nothing to be
worried about again we do this for the
safety of our vehicles as well as today
we had astronauts on our vehicle so even
bigger reason for us to make sure that
we have safe weather for them to fly and
just a reminder for everyone still tuned
in it takes about 40 minutes for all of
this propellant to come off of the
Falcon 9 and while it is offloading that
launch escape system on Dragon which is
designed to pull the capsule away if
there's any issue with the rocket or
anything on the pad that is still armed
so we're gonna continue to stay with
this until all the propellants off and
then we'll see the launch escape system
get disarmed Bob and Doug will be able
to open up their visors again the launch
the crew access arm will swing back out
and link up with dragon and make their
way off and then down the tower at the
pad but if you're just now tuning in no
launch today we did have to scrub
because of weather we're gonna be moving
to our second attempt on Saturday just a
little bit earlier in the afternoon just
gonna continue to stand by as this
propellant comes off we heard a call
that everything was going nominally or
as expected so far and then once the all
the propellants off we should see Bob
and Doug make their way out of Dragon
shortly after
[Music]
and what you're seeing on your screen is
a live view of Bob and Doug on the right
side inside of dragon as they're waiting
for propellant to be removed from the
vehicle so that it is safe for them to
disarm the launch escape system
[Music]
and this will take a bit of time so we
are going to stay alive with you to
watch this as they exit the vehicle
eventually and come down from from
standing down on launch today
up until the point of the scrub we had a
really clean countdown weren't tracking
any issues with Falcon 9 or the Dragon
spacecraft so always a good thing to see
we did have to scrub because of that
weather to be a little bit more specific
we were still in violation of one of the
weather criterias it was the strength of
electric fields in the atmosphere that
the 45th Space Wing and other weather
operators are monitoring around the
launch pad and that's one of those roles
where we need a certain amount of time
if we're in a violent 50% potato unlocks
head you'll 85% eight you feel so the
propellant off load on Falcon nine
continuing to go well but we needed a
little bit more time if we were gonna be
able to clear that launch weather
constraint and since we do have an
instantaneous launch window today we
weren't able to make it so we hope for
better weather coming up on Saturday
where again our next launch attempt is
gonna be a 322 p.m. Eastern time and
we'll be able to go through everything I
mean we we saw them get suited up they
had a great ride out to the pad all of
their initial checks on both the suits
with pressure checks and communication
checks went well able to get the dragon
hatch closed the launch escape system
arm and Falcon 9 started its fueling
just now I'm able to make a good weather
window today
and as John I said earlier was just
another great rehearsal today I don't
think you can get enough practice doing
this so when Saturday comes or when we
the day that we can actually launch the
vehicle Bob and Doug and the NASA and
SpaceX team are fully prepared with just
an extra rehearsal on the belt now as we
had talked a couple of times throughout
our countdown the weather is a lot more
complex when we're launching humans you
have some more stringent requirements in
place not only around the pad but in the
case of this launch today we're also
looking at whether the entire asset
corridor as we call it so basically the
entire way that they were flying up the
east coast of the United States and this
launch today we're monitoring that
weather because those are areas that if
they have an asset abort or basically
dragon firing off of the Falcon 9 while
they're flying into space we have to
make sure that conditions are good in
the sea states around those areas just
so they're not going to be landing in
the middle of a hurricane which we did
have a tropical storm forming right off
the coast of South Carolina today just
to help complicate things along and
people might be asking if we knew the
weather was going to be a little iffy
today why continue to countdown well
that is the reason why we do all these
checks all the way to countdown in
Florida the weather is you know pretty
sporadic sometimes a thunderstorm or
hurricane will pass through within 20
minutes it's gone and we could have
clear skies for a safe launch so we
continued as scheduled
standard procedure again to just
continuing to continue to monitor
weather all the way down to the last
minutes of the count and we see what
happened so today unfortunately we did
scrub for weather but we will attempt
again this Saturday on May 30th
and Dan just a couple of things to add
on there right now we are 11 minutes
after the scrub was called liquid oxygen
and feel they're coming off of the first
stage hard to tell from the view it's
still a little misty around the tank
because there's LOX on board but we're
between half and a third of each of the
fuel and lox tanks filled on the first
stage so propellant coming out right
there plan the second stage fuel tank is
offloading that's going slower but it's
also a smaller tank it doesn't take very
long to your load it or to offload it
the other thing that we're working on is
the high pressure helium spheres as well
as the nitrogen spheres for the landing
leg system the pressure will be brought
down on those eventually getting it down
low enough to where people can re-enter
the pad area so right now the team is
preparing once they get up permission
the SpaceX ingress egress technician
team will come back inside the caution
area around the pad make their way up
when conditions are right open up the
hatch and assist the astronauts
out of the dragon I'd like to point out
that for those who are wondering whether
or not having gone through this putting
propellant pressurization gas is on
getting fairly close to launch weather
that has done anything to wear out the
Falcon 9 or the dragon the answer is no
if you can recall the Falcon 9 is
designed for at least 10 flights and
about time we get up to a temp flight
will be doing testing to find that we've
probably got enough margin to continue
keep flying so this is the very first
flight of a new first stage in a new
second stage so we've not we haven't
even gotten through the first flight and
in all of our margin calculations we
also take into account the fact that we
may scrub a launch so even today's
operation where we have pressurized and
we stressed the vehicle a little bit
that's taken into account in our design
and our qualification testing the other
good thing is that the most stressing
part of the flight for the Falcon 9 on
the first stage is the reentry so we
didn't even get through that so we're
sitting here on the pad it's a fairly
straightforward situation and not
stressing on the Falcon 9 and on the
Dragon spacecraft with the human rating
factors to carry crew there is enough
factors of safety margins of safety
redundancy that just having two people
on board and closing the hatch and even
pressurizing the propellant system does
not eat into the margins of the
automatic sequences that we use
routinely both at the launch sites
Kennedy Space Center Cape Canaveral even
Vandenberg Air Force Base as well as in
our Texas test site for first and second
stage those sequences are running
propellant is coming off of the vehicle
per plan and we see Bob and Doug up in
the Dragon spacecraft just waiting when
we can get up there open the hatch and
help them egress and come on back down
the tower and the other thought I had
Dan and Jessi is right now we are coming
up what would have been t0 and I'm
wondering 10 minutes from now whether
the weather officer would turn around
and say yes it turned good you just
didn't have a long enough window we only
had one second and we needed 10 minutes
so we'll have to ask offline that say
hey did the weather conditions improve
and one thing I'll tag on to that dan
was mentioning and Jesse we're talking
about the launch opportunities the
launch window does move earlier on
Saturday a little bit so it just
happened to be orbital dynamics ed today
if you want to go to the International
Space Station and you want to launch
northeast which is the approved
trajectory you have to go right at four
thirty three thirty five p.m. Eastern
Daylight Saving Time you pick another
day the T zero moves it's just luck of
the draw
we might have been doing this at 8:00 in
the morning when we were getting
lightning or we could have been doing it
a few hours from now when conditions may
have been acceptable so in the end we
can all look at Isaac Newton and
Johannes Kepler for orbital dynamics
telling us when do we launch and that
stuck us right in the middle of a period
of bad weather so there's there's my
science lesson for today Tim jesse
appreciate that helped soften the blow
just moving past that t minus zero time
but for anybody if you're just now
tuning in wondering why Falcon 9 is
still sitting there on the pad as we
move past that t0 we did have a scrub
for weather today just not able to clear
all those constraints we keep a very
close eye on the weather around the pad
and their whole way looks for weather
right now Bob and Doug are still inside
weather yeah I just wanted to give you
some more words on the scrub rationale
yeah so we basically scrubbed due to
three rules that were violating both
altar II would have been expected to
clear 10 minutes after hour to zero time
and those three were natural lightning
the few Mills and the attached anvil
[Music]
yeah we tap EJ we appreciate that update
we can see some raindrops on the windows
and just figured that whatever it was
was too close to the launch pad at the
time we needed it not to be so we
appreciate that understand that
everybody's probably a little bit bummed
out it's just part of the deal everybody
was ready today and we appreciate that
and the ship was great and we'll do it
again I think on Saturday copy all and
yeah we concur and appreciate your
resilience sitting there in the vehicle
for us
we got beat up nothing better than being
prime crew on a new spaceship
copy that
all right some some great words from Bob
and Doug they're feeling good inside
dragon they'll be ready to go when we
make our next attempt on Saturday right
now we're just still waiting for all of
the fuel to come off the Falcon 9 rocket
out of a block of fuel roughly 20% and
today to fuel 36% into that call right
there we're still at a little over 20%
on fuel our p1 and lox liquid oxygen on
the first stage and then at about 26
percent on our p1 on that second stage
so again it takes about 40 minutes once
the process starts so we should have
right around 30 minutes or so until all
that fuels off and then the crew will
get the go to disarm the launch escape
system will see that crew access arm
swing back into place and they can begin
to egress or get out of the Dragon
spacecraft
and you heard it live that weather
update of what we violated we were just
10 minutes off unfortunately but again
today was an instantaneous launch and as
John explained it's due to the orbital
mechanics and making sure that at the
time we launched it will allow us to get
to the space station on time and
accurately so you can see on your right
screen Bob and Doug are patiently
waiting they do still have their visors
on and still strapped into their seats
the launch escape system is still armed
right now as we are offloading fuel and
will not disarm until prop offload is
complete and this is just to ensure the
safety of Bob and Doug and make sure
that they can egress safely from the
rocket
[Music]
and just a reminder today just this
first attempt we're gonna be right back
here looking like on Saturday for
attempt number two launch America's not
going anywhere
so still on the track to get Bob and
Doug into space and get this career
dragon up to the International Space
Station so it's always it's always good
if you're gonna scrub probably rather
scrub for weather than an issue on
either Falcon 9 or dragon and we weren't
tracking any issues with the flight
systems throughout our countdown today
everything passed with leak checks on
the hatches and the crew suits all the
communications working great
all the teams were ready to go so John I
said always nice to have a little bit
more practice and we'll be right back at
it on Saturday what would this launch be
if it wasn't even more exciting to try
and launch today and now we have to push
into Saturday's really got it bill yes
hey Dan and Jesse another thought
crossed my mind while I'm watching the
diagram here showing fuel is just about
off first and second stage we're down
under 10% LOX is also just about off of
it a lot shorter yep getting the
announcement cools roughly 20 page -
feels at 20% stage 1 LOX is under 10% so
just continue continuing to come off of
the vehicle as expected on the monitor
Bob and dog continue with visors down
there launch escape system is armed as
we've mentioned if there is anything
that we're happen to go wrong right now
they still have the viable pad abort
means something that we demonstrated way
back in 2015 on one of these webcasts
when we fired the Dragon capsule using
the 8 super Draco's off of the launch
pad and it splashed down offshore in the
Atlantic Ocean so they're staying there
with the system armed until all the
hazards that are essentially removed and
we bring the crew access arm around them
[Music]
we're standing by a minute we're gonna
listen to launch director talking to the
weather officer
[Music]
and if you're just now tuning in we did
not launch today we did have a scrub
because of weather but if as we were
saying we are looking forward to trying
this again on Saturday our launch time
on Saturday will be another
instantaneous window so we'll have to
have the weather cooperate again now
launch time will be at 3:22 p.m. Eastern
I think of our last weather update put
us at about 40% probability of violation
John I can check me real quick yeah Dan
what I saw coming out of the air force
was 40 percent probability of violation
I believe it's always tough because they
report in terms of violation and the
optimist have to subtract that from a
hundred percent to go a 60 percent
chance I'll plan my picnic we were
listening the SpaceX launch director
Mike Taylor was talking to the launch
weather officer asking about the three
criteria that scrubbed us today it
sounds like in another minute or two the
lightning and the attached anvil cloud
rules will clear the force still
bouncing around so hey we may need
several more minutes before that one
would clear so we'd need even longer
than 10 minutes in the window today it
looks like for all the rules to clear
that brings up what I wanted to mention
a little while ago I got lost listening
to the weather brief but there are a lot
of folks are going why an instantaneous
launch window for Falcon 9 and Dragon
now typically when we go to the space
station when we do the mission planning
it's an instantaneous window
there may be enough performance in the
rocket to launch somewhere in a
five-minute period but you've got to
pick a time in there but in the case of
Falcon 9 once we start propellant load
at t-minus 35 minutes it doesn't matter
so much if you can move 5 or 10 minutes
left or right because the whole sequence
is scripted we do the flight analysis
assuming that the temperatures of the
propellants are below a certain amount
so that we know how much performance is
available to the rocket how much margin
we're gonna have so essentially if you
start the countdown you know 4 hours 8
hours out like we're doing today and you
have a very short window once you get
our propellant loading at t-minus 35
minutes you have to go as soon as you
get to 0 we don't have the ability to
stop the countdown wait 5 minutes
now sudden the liquid oxygen starts
warming up from 340 degrees below zero
in the ground system and that changes
how much performance you get carrying
into orbit and we don't want to cut into
those margins now if we had had
something like a four-hour window which
some communication satellites have we
could actually get down to almost zero
hold the count D tank the Falcon 9 wait
a while it takes us about an hour and a
half reload a whole new batch of cold
liquid oxygen and fuel from the big
storage tank that we've got there at pad
39a and try to launch again but in that
case you have to be able to launch you
know about an hour and a half or so
later after you scrub and in the case of
the international space station an hour
and a half from now it's nowhere near
where we need to be the performance of
the Falcon 9 and the dragon so today
it's a combination we start the day with
a concurrent second window window for
the Falcon 9
regardless of what the so there's a
little explanation for folks who are
wondering why we have such a tight
window just about off of the standard
things are clocking right along for the
forty minute timeline everything looks
good and we'll wait to hear that we're
clear and then when we get the call for
Bob and Doug to go ahead and disarm
launch escape system and the crew access
arm will watch come back out Center
itself around the Dragon hatch and then
the ingress team will go up there and
open the hatch thank you for the science
lesson John I no charge we did hear a
quick call of the crew there we should
be just under ten minutes away from that
prop prop offload completing it looks
like we're just tracking 15 and there we
have the confirmation stage to offloads
complete and we should have now just the
RP 1 so that densified propellant or the
RP 1 is kerosene we should be under 10%
willow under 10 minutes until that's off
and then we'll step through those events
we were discussing where they'll be able
to disarm the launch escape system get
the arm back out there and Bob and Doug
can begin to eggs at the Dragon
spacecraft
[Music]
[Music]
still not the friendliest skies in the
background that is Florida though the
weather is constantly changing over
there which is why we always have to
keep an eye on it through every single
launch that we have out there father
Doug are patiently waiting as you can
see that is a live view of them on the
crew Dragon vehicle as they're waiting
prop offload to complete second stage
prop offload is complete we are just
waiting on first stage total is complete
waiting on stage one fuel roughly five
minutes or so
[Music]
and again the launch escape system is
still armed we are waiting for a prop
offload to complete before they disarm
that and then they will be able to
egress from the crew dragon vehicle we
just heard we should be just under five
minutes away from the last of that fuel
coming out of the Falcon 9 first stage
and then we'll see those events start to
pick back up and we'll see the crew arm
swing back out they've been in those
seats for a couple hours now they
typically get inside of Dragon a little
over two and a half hours ahead of
launch so they've been strapped into
these seats for quite a while
they aren't custom sized though so there
is comfortable and as snug as possible
obviously since they're going to be in
them for a really long time but most
importantly when you're doing that
splashdown at the very end of the
mission you it's your car seat and
splashing down or landing on land is not
the most gentle of procedures and a
capsule so just really making sure that
they're they're snug inside of that
Dragon capsule but we should be a little
under five minutes away from the prop
offload being completed
and as Dan mentioned those suits are
custom made but the seats are also
custom fit for each astronaut as well
they do remain on crew dragon for this
mission for almost 24 hours about so we
do want to make sure that they are
comfortable and make sure that these
suits and the the seats are comfortable
enough for them to stay in that position
for a while
I believe when they get into orbit they
are allowed to get out of their seats
and get a little bit more comfortable
but it's a long ride for them yeah once
once they do get on orbit they are able
to get out of the seats and actually out
of their suits - since for this flight
path today they was gonna take him about
19 hours so Bob and Doug will activ
would actually have had about eight
hours to sleep on board the Dragon
capsule so
we weren't able to launch today though
the rendezvous on Saturday should be
very similar to what we would have had
if we launched today where it'll take
him about 19 hours to get to the
International Space Station
so they'll launch and they'll have a
number of different events that we'll be
able to walk you through including
manual piloting of Dragon and just
really putting the spacecraft through
all of the paces before it arrives at
the International Space Station because
again this this is a test flight and
this is this last test before we certify
the Dragon spacecraft for regular crewed
flights which we'll just be bringing up
those long durations six month maybe
even a year long missions right and it's
it should be a very exciting test flight
because it's pretty much like an actual
mission when Bob and Doug get on the
station they will be before performing
some research while they're up there and
performing tests and and doing some
final things for this demonstration
mission yeah but I mean just for right
now we are just gonna continue to stay
with them until we see them come out of
Dragon because the launch escape system
still armed while we wait for this
propellant offload to complete that's
just done as a safety measure anytime
you have rocket propellants beneath you
you want to make sure that we have a
good way for them to get out of the way
and so we should be within just a couple
of minutes for that final bit of rp1
coming off the first stage and then
we'll hear the crew get the go to disarm
that launch escape system we'll see the
crew access arm swing back in but if
you're just tuning in expecting them to
be in space we did have a scrub today
due to weather our next launch attempt
is going to be this Saturday May 30th at
3:22 p.m. Eastern Time and just like we
did today we're gonna be bringing you
every single step of the way it's gonna
look a little familiar if you watched
all of today's but it's going to be just
as exciting
I can imagine it might even be more
exciting with all the anticipation that
we've hyped this launch up for her with
already going through it all today but
again the more practice we have you know
the better off we will be hopefully next
launch attempt we will have a flawless
launch and actually be able to lift off
with good weather weather is going to be
the big thing that will continue to
watch that was the culprit today for our
scrub and our initial weather reports
already looking at about a 40%
possibility of violation probability of
violation so as John I was saying the
optimist and us have to say that's 60%
good so we're gonna look we're gonna
look at the good side of this and that's
roughly what we were in the days leading
up to this we won't have a rogue
tropical storm forming off of South
Carolina on us on Saturday but Florida
weather will always be dynamic so let's
continue to track and hopefully get a
good chance hit that window on Saturday
and just a reminder everything else on
the vehicle and for the mission was
looking good today it was just the
weather which as John I said earlier and
Lauren even referred to him mentioning
this weather is the one thing that we
actually cannot control on our missions
so unfortunately it did cause us to
scrub today but the healthy the the
vehicles are healthy Bob and Doug we're
ready and they should be ready to go
again with the next to launch launch
attempt on Saturday
[Music]
just looking at our data looks like that
our p1 is just about all out so we'll
just kind of stand by for a few more
moments hopefully we get that call soon
John I
yeah I was going to while we were
waiting to hear the call that the last
percentage of feel is off I was gonna
comment on Jessie's discussion rod it
was just the weather I think during this
countdown there were more words said
about the weather then I'm listening
right now to whether discussion in the
background
and again for people wondering if we
knew that we did have bad weather will
no even call this morning okay well we
do monitor this all the way down all the
way down to the final minutes of the
countdown and with Florida weather being
pretty sporadic sometimes we have even
hurricanes coming through or bad weather
coming through and passing 20 minutes
later and having good weather for a
launch so this is why we continued to
attempt to launch today but
unfortunately 40-0 today weather was not
on our side yeah Jesse this John again I
dropped off to listen to a weather
discussion they were just giving the
times the lightning rule went green so
we could have gone with a lightning
concern the attached kanva were all
cleared but the field mill rule is
expected to clear at 58 minutes after
the hour so that's another four and a
half minutes from now so we we were
close but we needed about 25 minutes
later launch time it does remind me at
risk of offending some people but the
old saying that says it's better to be
on the ground wishing you were flying
then flying wishing you were on the
ground yes definitely safety first
always and making sure that when Bob and
Doug do fly they are flying safely and
as planned so again this is standard
procedure for us to make sure that they
do have a safe flight to the
International Space Station
[Music]
all right well for now we're just
continuing to stand by expecting the
call that all of that prop has now been
offloaded from Falcon 9 that thing
vehicle takes to nominal TV set points
or Icarus
[Music]
at this moment the launch escape system
still armed once the prop offload is
complete that'll be the next step in our
procedures to have Bob and Doug begin to
make their way out of Dragon
[Music]
it'll be counting on one le but we have
the prompt here for nominal crew egress
okay so we're ready for launch scape
system to serve as a firm ready for
launch escape disarmed MMD copies
you guys already will ya large teams
ready to go ahead advise the crew a
dragon SpaceX you copy that discussion
so with that you are go for disarming
launch escape system for section 2 of
5.10 zero
for that market section Q guitar being
the launch of equipment all right that
was the call we are waiting for
propelling off of Falcon 9
so dr. Lee Bob Bank and now going to
disarm the launch escape system on
dragon and once that's disarmed those
eight super Draco engines will be out of
the mix i think bagon they put them have
been disarmed in human memory copy that
we concur
and showing then confirm the launch
escape system has been disarmed and
dragon SpaceX with that confirmation you
are go to open your visors and procedure
section tree
hey we'll open the visors and go to
Section three
as you heard and you can see Baba Dutt
can now open their visors and get ready
for exiting the vehicle again they kept
their visors on while the launch escape
system was armed while prop offloading
was continuing and that is just to make
sure that they are safe now that there
is no more prop propellant on any of the
vehicles they are safe to have disarmed
the launch escape system and now are
getting ready for that crew arm to swing
back the hatch to open and for them to
egress vex dragon with an update for
holding in three decimal four and we're
ready for secret ation when you are copy
that
we'll wait for the closeout team to open
the hatch and verify clearance and then
we can execute see rotation
captain
and there's that crew arm swinging back
towards dragon once that crew arm is in
place they will be able to open the
hatch on crew dragon bobbin doug seats
will rotate back out of launch position
so that they can safely get out of their
seats and egress the vehicle
and we heard they'll have what they
called nominal egress so just the normal
procedures for getting them out of the
capsule that means the the same closeout
team that was there to get them in will
be able to assist as they come out
they'll arrive and get that hatch open
then they'll be able to rotate the seats
that will rotate Bob and Doug pretty
much forward where they'll be in the
original position that the seats were
configured when they made their way into
drag and it just gets them a little bit
out and under the displays and makes
getting in and out of the capsule a
little bit easier they've been in those
seats for about three hours at this
point so definitely a long day for the
crew as they woke up about six hours
prior to our t-minus zero had their
breakfast which we confirmed with steak
and eggs please for duck Carly and then
they proceeded through all of the suit
up and the truck the trip to the pad
making their way inside dragon where
they've been for about the last three
hours at this point we were on track for
an on-time liftoff right at 4:30 3 p.m.
Eastern Time but did have to scrub a
little under 17 minutes before launch
due to weather so for now we've
offloaded all of the propellant off of
Falcon 9 the launch escape system has
been disarmed at Kerr access arm is back
right up next to dragon as you can see
in that view on the left pretty soon
we'll see the team's arrived to get the
hatch open get Bob and Doug out they'll
make their way back to crew quarters and
their quarantine it is important to note
that throughout the entire process of
them getting into Dragon suiting up all
of those different steps they maintain
that same quarantine that they've been
since for about two weeks now and that
is specifically for events like today
where we have to scrub and just go to
another day so we don't want to we don't
want to break that quarantine once we're
putting them into that launch vehicle
and that's a standard quarantine that we
have for any crew members flying to the
International Space Station the current
kovat 19 pandemic obviously puts a
little bit of extra pressure and a
little bit of an extra spotlight on that
but they're following a lot of the same
procedures that we have in place just to
keep crewmembers healthy before they go
and spend several months in space in an
enclosed environment with just a couple
of other people right and it's a little
bit more difficult to get them help on
the space station right so we want to
make sure that they when they do head up
to the space station that they are fully
healthy so this again is standard
procedure not just because of this
pandemic that's going on this is a
standard procedure for astronauts to
quarantine prior to heading to the
station
[Music]
and as Dan mentioned this is a standard
procedure to exit the vehicle as well we
did scrub today but this is not an
emergency State this is standard
procedure this is something that is
practiced and rehearsed and made sure
that we do follow our standard
procedures to make sure that everything
is still safe Bob and Doug exit safely
and go back into quarantine and get
ready for our next launch attempt
looks like they've gotten a chance to
stretch their legs though yeah Jesse I'm
monitoring along in the scrub procedure
right now they're getting the goes to
get the folks back to the pad the crew
that'll open the hatch so they have
notified the team chief launch
engineering to return to the pad as a
reminder around the pad the Air Force
sets up Air Force NASA set up roadblocks
to make sure nobody gets into the hazard
area so they will head to the roadblocks
they'll pull them open so that they can
drive to the parents so launch director
I think is estimating is still about 15
minutes for the crew to drive all the
way down out to 39 a get up the tower
and then begin operations on the hatch
they have confirmed that the purge of
the dragon service section which is
nitrogen during the countdown to avoid
you know an oxygen leak that is back on
air now the crew access arm is on air so
they're ready for the the
egress team to get up into the tower but
it's going to take them a little bit
still I think to drive down the road in
the vehicles and go up the elevator
but everything continuing to run poor
per a normal scrub countdown which we
have had the opportunity to practice
with the crew in for example the dry
dress rehearsal last Saturday after we
had done the static fire the Falcon 9
the day before
and I've been seeing a few questions
people asking why aren't we just trying
to launch tomorrow
as John I was talking us through there's
some very specific times you have to
identify when you're gonna be able to
link up with the International Space
Station you only have so much fuel which
can only generate so much energy to make
sure you're gonna intersect with the
station which is flying at over 17,000
miles an hour so you're hitting one
bullet with another bullet some of our
other launch attempts are able to make
it station but have much longer drag to
prevent us from losing comms we're going
to be switching to umbilical at this
time I'm going to be unmerge ink on one
but we'll keep you updated here on
dragged around
okay yeah with you the key drip a
countdown with a little over three
minutes will plan by for your next call
an umbilical copy the crew getting a
call they're just gonna reconfigure some
communications but as to why we're not
launching say tomorrow on corn count on
one loops are lurched
but when we pick our launch attempts we
also have to take in mind some of the
human factors of these attempts some of
these other launch attempts may exist
but it would require dragon taking in
excess of 30 or more hours potentially
to reach the station which could wreak
some havoc with the sleep shift cycles
not only for Bob and Doug but also for
the crew onboard station that has to
line up their sleep schedule with Bob
and Doug as they arrive and the crews on
station and Bob and Doug will be
operating off of Greenwich Mean Time
once they get there dragon SpaceX comm
check umbilical dragon loud and clear on
a Billiken on copy have you the same
still getting good combi tween the crew
and the core are here in Hawthorne but
really just to sum it up we pick our
launch attempts for a number of reasons
not just can we make it to the station
but just how long is it gonna take to
get there and that's why Saturday is
going to be our best option we're going
to be targeting that one at 3:22 p.m.
Eastern Time for our next attempt and
it'll be a little over 19 maybe a little
over 20 hours until we actually arrive
at the space station if we're able to
get off the ground on Saturday
and then this gives Bob and Doug you
know a few days to kind of shake off the
nerves from today's launch attempt give
them some some more time to rest and
again get ready for our launch attempt
on Saturday
[Music]
[Music]
and if you're just now joining us we did
scrub our demonstration - mission today
and as John mentioned we are waiting for
the egress team to make it back to the
launch pad head up the tower and help
the crew or help Bob and Doug egress the
vehicle
[Music]
dragon SpaceX foreclosed all teams tests
go ahead
yeah the close all team has arrived at
the pad and they are proceeding to the
white room
[Music]
you heard that call out the egress team
is at the pad and are proceeding to meet
Bob and Doug in the white room where
they can open the hatch and help them
exit the vehicle
[Music]
but we'll continue to stick with Bob and
Doug until we see that hatch get open
and them start to make their way out and
then they're going to and there we can
get some views once more back at the pad
you can see that egress team moving back
in they were wearing the black clean
suits that we saw was they were helping
Bob and Doug get into the dragon just
several hours ago they're now gonna get
on the elevator make their way back up
down the crew access arm and then we'll
get that dragon side hatch opened
and as we saw earlier this is a very
tall structure but that elevator is
pretty quick there so we saw them enter
the bottom of the tower it should be a
very short time before they make it to
the top and are able to get to the white
room and open the hatch for Bob and Doug
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you want
and should just be a few more moments
will see that closeout team make their
way back into the crew access arm and
down the hatchway and again if you are
just now tuning in we did have that
scrub just about a little under 17
minutes before launch our next launch
attempt is going to be this Saturday May
30th at launch time it's going to be
another instantaneous launch time it's
going to be 322 p.m. Eastern Time over
there in Florida
assuming an on-time launch it'll be a
pretty similar flight that we were
looking at today where it'll be roughly
about 19 hours before they make that
initial contact to the International
Space Station they'll get on orbit and
execute a series of five different burns
to gradually raise their orbit until
they're just a few hundred meters below
the station and maybe a few kilometers
behind and then they'll do all of the
final approach initiation maneuvers and
by that point the team here in Hawthorne
will be working very closely with the
team down in Houston in the
International Space Station flight
control room weather for Saturday still
not ideal but it's roughly what we
started out with today where we have
about a 40% chance possibility of
violation and it'll be tracking a lot of
the same issues with cumulus clouds of
potential precipitation we'll also be
keeping an eye on all of the downrange
weather it looks like we're seeing some
people start to make their way into the
crew access arm now so we should see
them get that dragon side hatch open in
just a few minutes but as a reminder
we'll be looking at weather around the
launch pad and whether downrange in
their their flight path on the way to
orbit and that's always checked just in
case they have to do any kind of
emergency maneuver and land down in the
Atlantic Ocean we will be making sure
that the weather is it acceptable levels
all the way until they're into space
so you can see the team coming down now
should see the hatch open momentarily
and then we can begin to get Bob and
Doug out of the Dragon spacecraft
and again we are staying live until Bob
and Doug are safely out of crew dragon
you can see on your left hand screen the
team getting ready to open the hatch for
them and help them out of their seats
and at this point the launch escape
system has been disarmed that was done
after we successfully offloaded all of
the propellants from the first and
second stage of the Falcon 9 rocket
there our propellants loaded in a dragon
so the teams looked like they were just
doing what we call kind of a sniff test
so using a portable detector just to
assess the atmosphere around the dragon
that capsule itself before they get the
hatch open and bring Bob and Doug out
all of this is standard safety
procedures for egressing the vehicle
this is to ensure the safety of the crew
as well as Bob and Doug dragon SpaceX
for status and the closeout team is at
the white room
they are configuring the crew arm for
egress expected to take no earlier than
10 minutes
there should be just about 10 minutes as
a reminder there in the white room we
walk through that a little bit earlier
in our coverage this morning the white
room name simply because of its color
and that's something that started all
the way back during earlier Gemini
missions and that is literally the last
place on planet earth where astronauts
are standing before they get loaded into
this vehicle it has an environmental
control apparatus and a seal that it can
put right up against the Dragon
spacecraft just to keep all of that dust
dirt Florida humidity and drag these
caps we're right at three hours and see
rotation I just wanted to check in with
you on comfort levels
I'd say no changes day it hasn't been so
bad at all and obviously at this point
with the launch escape system disarms we
have loosened up straps and got her feet
out of the straps on the bottom of the
seats a little more comfortable anyway
oh yeah looks comfortable
[Music]
[Music]
right now the closeout team just gonna
take a couple of minutes to configure
the white room they'll set up a seal
between it and a Dragon spacecraft just
to make sure we're not letting anything
from the surrounding environment get
into that spacecraft which is kept very
pristine obviously for the crew members
once they're inside I will also they
have a small bridge that just connects
the crew arm to the capsule itself just
making sure they have a nice clear path
for their entrance and exit from the
spacecraft so should just be a few more
minutes we'll see that hatch get opened
and then our crew members can start to
make their way out and you heard seat
rotation they rotate the seats prior to
their actual flight to where they're a
little bit more parallel to the ground
and that just puts them directly in
front of those displays we'll see them
rotate down just giving them easy access
to get out of the capsule
and as Dan mentioned we want to keep
Fahd out of the capsule the Fahd is for
an object debris so that's basically
anything that does not belong inside of
the vehicle so not just like dirt and
dust but just anything that was not
meant to be inside of there should not
be there so we are doing everything as a
standard procedure to make sure that we
do keep Vlad out especially since this
is going to be another attempt and
another opportunity for Fahd to enter
the vehicle we as they're exiting we
still make sure that we keep everything
basically like a cleanroom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dragon SpaceX you may hear some vehicle
venting and about context
[Music]
Jonah's burger here with the webcast
desk in Hawthorne California we are
continuing to wait for the crew to open
the side hatch we've got the camera
showing astronauts Doug Hurley Bob
Behnken inside visors are up they've
gotten their feet out of the restraints
gloves are off
in case of Doug it looks like and the
team is just outside the hatch they're
going through the sequence right now
make sure pressure checks are all good
make sure there are no concerns with
gases be it the propellants of the
vehicle or just nitrogen gas that we use
as a purge currently we are coming up on
about 50 minutes after the plan t0 to
just reiterate what Dan and Jesse have
been talking about earlier we had a good
countdown I had a lot of fun saying
there were no issues on Falcon 9 or
dragon of a technical sort the range was
ready to support the downrange weather
looked good in case dragon had to make a
unplanned abort splashdown in an escape
maneuver somewhere in the Atlantic and
we even had the once we get on orbit in
case dragon had to reenter and come back
early though weather was good in the
Pacific in case it had to come down so
everything was looking our way they
accept mother nature the weather it's
Florida and we got into the back end of
the tropical storm that has now gone
ashore and the Carolinas but
unfortunately that left everything
disrupted just enough
we violated several the weather rules
and we did not have enough time for them
to go green green meaning where the rain
says conditions are clear and you are
alright to launch we were still read on
those rules and that was the end of the
countdown for the day again we scrubbed
at t-minus 16 minutes 54 seconds that
was shortly before we were due to begin
loading the liquid oxygen on to the
second stage that was both the logical
breakpoint in the countdown procedure
where we could take a scrub without
loading one more propellant on the
vehicle and at the same time that was
when the range gave us the final bad
news that we weren't going to get green
conditions before the clock ran out of
t0 so continuing to watch right now is
the crew works to get the hatch open
they send final commands making sure
that everything's go once the hatch is
open the ground crew can verify that
there is nothing in the way under the
seats that duck and Bob are sitting in
and we will get the seat rotation again
get them back a little bit more vertical
they're more on their backs right now in
the launch position
so they'll rotate then they'll help them
out of the seats and they'll come back
out and down the arm and off of the
tower
Dragons SpaceX for status
it looks like the close all team is
inflating the hatch see the arm CEO
right now
you
you
all right we've been quiet for a few
minutes but if you're just now tuning in
we did not launch today we did have to
scrub out today's mission due to weather
we were just under 17 minutes away from
our t0 time at 433 Eastern when the call
was made we were still in violation of a
few of the weather constraints that just
are really there to inform teams when
it's safe to launch so we're looking at
weather both around the pad and weather
all the way on the way to orbit for them
so we did have to scrub since then we've
been able to get all of the propellant
off of Falcon 9 the launch escape system
has been disarmed and right now the
closeout teams are there in the white
room so right at the end of that crew
access arm they're configuring the big
seal that goes around the Dragon capsule
just to make sure its environment as
isolated from all that nasty Florida
weather and then they'll be able to get
the hatch open and we'll get Bob and
Doug back out
we're coming up on just under an hour
since the plan t0 again if you're just
joining us well we've been here summing
up for a while standby first - check
[Music]
close all teams still working to do the
hatch Co inflation expect another five
to ten minutes okay we scrubbed at t
minus 16 minutes 54 seconds we violated
three weather rules the weather rules
finally cleared up but it was long after
the plan t0 the SpaceX egress team did
return to the pad they were sent through
the roadblocks that surround the pad
demarcating where the hazard areas teams
up on the crew arm and as you just heard
spacex talking - knots Bob and Doug
they're working the seal around Dragon
then we make sure that Dragon capsule
pressure is equalized with the crew arm
and then we'll go into the hatch opening
sequence so we've still got several more
minutes we'll carry that as we go a
couple of points to bring up once the
crew comes off of the dragon and comes
back down goes back to the crew quarters
to D suit we will be SpaceX for
awareness we're going to command the
vehicle into a patch open in preparation
for a hatch opening ok that's good
that'll get them into the sequence to
make sure that the pressures inside and
outside note this will equalize cabin
pressure so you may notice something in
there okay thank you so as I started to
mention once everybody's off we'll leave
the Falcon 9 dragon the career arm where
they are that is in the launch support
position there's no plan to come back
down to horizontal the
vehicle is designed to stay vertical now
if we were to find something wrong
during the countdown as we go through
data review that could mean that we have
to come horizontal as we did late last
night
early this morning as we were working a
ground issue on the transporter director
and then we went right back up but
currently no plans to come horizontal
will stay vertical up to the next launch
attempt on Saturday there will also be
as is typical engineers will go through
all of the data they collected today and
then there will be a report out in
what's called a delta launch readiness
review probably this Friday before we
get into the next launch attempt on
Saturday that's where the engineering
disciplines will brief management a
chief engineer launch director mission
director the NASA customer where we
stand on today's countdown what we
learned as well as our readiness to
proceed into another countdown attempt
but currently at a Kennedy Space Center
at historic pad 39a we're getting ready
for the hatch opening and the crew to be
able to leave drag and come back down
get out of their suits and wait to go
another day hopefully this coming
Saturday the 30th
and Dragon SpaceX sure you see vehicles
in panitch open the a Vivi's are now
open and that nitrox injection is
complete yep we felt it and heard it and
and Dragons SpaceX for status the close
our team is working is stepping into
hatch opening up
you
you
you
Jonah's burger back here at the webcast
s in Hawthorne California we've got
another camera up and you can see the
side-by-side view on the monitor
astronauts Bob and Doug inside waiting
for the hatch to come open we're still
in the middle of the equalization step
make sure that pressure inside the
dragon is equal to the external the
ambient pressure so that when we open
the hatch just comes open without any
extra force you can also see the SpaceX
team is up alongside the capsule they
are removing essentially the thermal
protection devices you know for example
if you have a door handle on your
automobile if you're going to have to
re-enter from outer space you're gonna
have to put a small heat shield over
that door handle otherwise any kind of
protrude rinses cavities could be
subject to burn up so they have to take
their time make sure that we get all of
the thermal protection safety devices
off so if they can then get access to
the mechanism that go ahead and bring
the hatch open so at your walk what you
are watching right now on the Left
monitor is the egress team going through
the steps this is typical we're not
hearing any chatter over the pad nut
that they're having any problems they
just take their time and make sure that
everybody's ready to bring the hatch
open when they finally get there so
currently we are t plus one hour and 11
minutes or so since the planned launch
obviously we're still on the ground
we're going through the post scrub
operations to bring astronauts Doug
Hurley and Bob bacon out of the capsule
and you can see now H's coming open
there's a view from the camera inside
the capsule you can see the hatch area
crew gave a quick wave to the ground
crew when it came open and right now
they should be inspecting the area
underneath the seats so that we can
command the seats to rotate back into
the ingress egress position make it a
little easier on Bob and Doug to get in
and out of the seats
dragon SpaceX just for awareness they
have a few more steps in their procedure
and they should be calling to us for
seat rotation shortly okay copy that yep
we see them working on that and this is
a lead into that we are ready for the
scene rotation how does this let us know
when you're ready to start
here the confirmation from the dragon
team talking to the astronauts that they
are just about ready to send the seat
rotation command again the ground crew
is verifying making sure that none of
the cargo that's packed in dragon
underneath the crew nothing is what is
in the way nothing came loose you're
looking at one row of crew seating but
there is you know as we've mentioned
before dragon designed to carry up to
seven but on this flight for example
much of the cargo that we're carrying is
loaded in various areas down below where
the astronauts are seated so they're
just verifying nothing's in the way so
that when they'd send the rotation
command the seats all pivot without
encumbrance
Dragons SpaceX we are initiating sea
rotation dragon copies were anyone
that call-out from the drug incor up to
the crew letting them know that we are
sending the commands from the ground to
rotate the seats and you can see
astronauts Doug Hurley Bob Behnken
rotating in their seat back to a more
comfortable position to get in and out
of the capsule
the dragon SpaceX seats are up right
thanks for the family effort today
helping us test our scrub timeline and
we'll see you saturday yeah we
appreciate those words everybody did
great today it was a great practice and
we'll do it again on Saturday everybody
has a phone we'll talk general oops
likewise well Dan we've heard it they've
got rotated the hatch is open the ground
crew is going to work to get the
astronauts out the SpaceX Dragon team
like the SpaceX Falcon 9 team is going
to be coming off of Council now as we
turn it over to the folks on the pad so
while we didn't launch it was a pretty
good countdown and scrub sequence so
we've got that good lesson learned under
our belt and we look forward to Saturday
having even better results when we get
close to t0 that's right always great
when we don't have any issues with the
capsule or the rocket which we didn't
today just had to fight that weather and
we'll be doing the same on Saturday we
are looking at about a 50% probability
of violation that's about where we were
today we did see it was all just a
matter of trying to line up correctly
and didn't make it today but we're gonna
try to get on Saturday right and it
sounds like we were just about half an
hour away from making the launch attempt
today with weather with 50 percent
weather chance on Saturday hopefully we
have a better day at t0 for liftoff but
we're definitely gonna all be back Jessi
myself and John I will be here in
Hawthorne to take you along every step
of the way we hope everyone else Tunes
in also because this is really gonna be
a monumental moment we're now gonna look
towards Saturday for America once again
launching US astronauts on American
Rockets from American soil with them
getting out of the capsule though that's
gonna do it for us here at Hawthorne
we're gonna send you back down to
Florida for one last check in with our
teams there so over to you marine Lauren
Leland if you're still sticking around
we're gonna be looking forward to
Saturday all right thanks a lot Danielle
we just were just all sitting here we
watched Bob Behnken just climb out of a
seat looks like he is out of crew dragon
now and Doug Hurley following suit no
pun intended
there we see Bob in the foreground and
Doug climbing out of crew dragon in the
background pad closeout team looks like
helping them out so any minute they're
gonna be basically just reversing course
coming back the way from whence they
came Leland I know you had a scrub years
back yeah Marie in 2008 we were having
breakfast and I never I never scrubbed
while I was in the vehicle but we were
having breakfast and we got a call from
the from the flight director saying that
two of the we had a these engine cutoff
sensors that were were bad two were bad
and the flight will say that you should
have to have three of four to fly and so
we all said we're not going to fly
unless we have them and I think we all
need to know that the flight rules are
there to protect you know our astronauts
and their families and and you know we
got very close today you know we
sometimes you get that launch fever that
we want to go ahead and destroy it
anyway but we we have these rules for a
reason and it's really important to
stick to the rules even in the heat of
battle even with you know dignitaries
here it's just you know the way that we
have to do it as operators that's a good
wet dress exercise you know went through
exercise all the systems nearly to t 0
which is incredible I believe this may
have been the first time Bob and Doug
are sitting on top of our in our vehicle
with a fueled rocket so that's pretty
cool for sure closing the hatch
exercising the environmental
life-support systems
doing that flight leak check I mean all
of this is a ton of learning that that
came out of here even if we didn't
ultimately go to space today
absolutely so we're getting a cool view
that we wouldn't have seen if they
launched they're making
they're way back down the crew access
arm and they are going to be turning the
corner they're heading to the stairs
that are going to take them down to the
elevator
passing the worm so yep they're heading
down the stairs now it's going to take
them down to the 255 foot level and then
they're going to be getting in the
elevator take them down to the ground
level and we'll do it again on Saturday
it's actually very reassuring that all
systems were go you know there was no
problems with the vehicle at all is
Lauren as you said and it was just some
weather and I think if we have that same
performance on Saturday and the weather
gods give us some give her some good
juju there we'll be good to go yes yes
please
I mean we were we were so close today I
hurt my heart if we had 10 more minutes
it sounded like we would have we
probably would have made it but I just
was not was not to be today and of
course we're gonna always do what is the
safest thing for the crew and as they
head into the elevator there we do want
to go over to operations and support
building 2 now where the NASA
Administrator Jim bridenstine is
standing by he would like to provide his
own thoughts now we'll go to him well
thank you Marie I know there's a lot of
disappointment today the weather got us
but I also want to say this was really
it was a great day for NASA it was a
great day for SpaceX I think our team's
worked together in a really impressive
way making good decisions all along so
here in this particular case we had just
simply too much electricity in the
atmosphere there wasn't really a
lightning storm or anything like that
but there was a concern that if we did
launch it could actually trigger
lightning and so we made the right
decision
we had the parameters set ahead of time
the teams work together and in the end
the right decision was made I will tell
you I've done a lot of interviews over
the last two days and in those
interviews I get asked over and over
again is there undue pressure here
people say to me with all of the
attention of the world on this launch
with all of the VIPs coming are you
gonna feel pressure on this launch and I
will tell you I as I've told you know
our teams under no circumstances should
anybody feel pressure if we are not
ready to go we simply do not go and I
will tell you I am proud so proud of our
teams working together to make the right
decision in this particular case we have
a lot to look forward to in just a few
short days on Saturday Saturday
afternoon we're gonna do it again here's
what we know
we are gonna launch American astronauts
on American Rockets from American soil
we're gonna do that we're very close I
also want to say that this was an
important milestone just today we did a
wet dress rehearsal we haven't done a
wet dress rehearsal with our astronauts
full gear before we've done a dry dress
rehearsal now we've done a dress a wet
dress so we learn a lot every time we do
these things this is no different and we
get a lot of great data from from doing
what we just did so today was a good day
for NASA it was a good day for for
SpaceX and we've got a lot to look
forward to so I want to say
congratulations to both of the teams and
let's go let's go get this done I know
we're up for it
Saturday's gonna be a great day and here
we go again so thank you to everybody
for all the great work Murray back to
you all right thank you so much those
were some great insights from Jim
bridenstine the NASA Administrator the
crews making their way back to astronaut
crew quarters where they're going to
remain in quarantine until Saturday
they've been in quarantine for two weeks
and there they will stay to keep them
safe and healthy for our next launch
attempt again we had to stand down from
launch today because of unfavorable
weather conditions around launch complex
39a but we're going to be ready to do
this again Saturday May 30th the new
launch time will be 322 p.m. and our
coverage will begin live here on NASA TV
at 11 o'clock in the morning Eastern
Time
Saturday so be sure to tune back in on
NASA television and nasa.gov /live if
you're watching it along online and we
will be back here to take you through it
every step of the way
thanks for sticking with us and we will
see you back here Saturday
you
you
you
[Music]
I've always thought like oh my gosh when
you go to space like you don't have to
grocery shop for like six months I think
it's gonna actually put me on a schedule
for eating I am horrible at eating at
all hours of the night I've missed line
I way also talking about all those boxes
that would give you up like that would
give away to the people people literally
get on their knees crying because
imagine those are families sometimes of
six and seven people in one little shack
take a burden of them having to go
outside to get their daily meals
[Music]
where dr if campaign we launched with a
piece of art since foundation to be able
to unite relief efforts for to fight
against OB so that we can help with
resources with the purchase of food kids
with the purchase of ventilators medical
supplies for doctors and nurses and so
far it's been it's been good for the we
continue to need help they don't have
the right protection they don't have the
mask the mythical stop building have the
proper protection and and it's getting
worse every day
they see me as a hero they see me as the
one that really understands what they're
going through because I come from there
and they've